bonjour andré goretti merci de répondre
à nos questions pourquoi cet appel à la
grève est pourquoi êtes vous opposé à la
vaccination obligatoire des sapeurs
pompiers
il s'agit tout simplement de savoir le
notre position à la remise en cause des
libertés individuelles ne sommes pas
contre la vaccination
nous nous exprimons aujourd'hui les
points de désaccord avec le projet de
loi enfin cette loi puisque ce n'est
plus un projet cette loi étendant idée
par le conseil constitutionnel et sa
parution est effective
donc un certain nombre d'entre nous
citoyens français à part entière ne sont
pas en accord avec l'obligation
vaccinale
quelles que soient les les principes
arrêtés par l'ordre détermination et
simplement de ces de faire valoir dans
cette attaque qui est profonde pour nous
on parle de grève illimitée concrètement
combien de temps peut durer votre
mouvement et est ce que vous allez quand
même intervenir quand tu auras le feu ou
des personnes en danger malgré cette
grève de fait que des concitoyens n'ai
pas d'inquiétude les services
départementaux d'incendié et secours à
l'obligation du service minimum donc
d'organiser un service minimum avait
fondé tenir en réquisitions de terres
francs en or des personnels pour activer
le service non simplement c'est un appui
h et d'un problème de deux talents
sociale qui n'existe plus le haut c'est
dans notre pays et nous avons découvert
au travers la communication médiatique
et autres c'est de cette obligation qui
a été affirmé par la loi il n'y a plus
de discussion sur la thématique qui est
plus qu'une thématique à sion la
problématique aujourd'hui de cette
pandémie
pourtant nous sommes en capacité de
l'acheter
même si les premiers jours de de cette
crise sanitaire était très difficile
pour nous puisque renault ne souhaitait
pas de protéger nous n'avions pas de
masque pas de matériel de protection
on nous demandait même de venir
travailler avec eux lorsque nous étions
touchés par le cos vite par l'aco ville
les dispositifs et évoluez aujourd'hui
nous nous sommes en capacité de gérer la
prise en charge des victimes touchées
par la copine avec des protocoles
famille
terre des consignes opérationnelle qui
nous permettent de protéger des victimes
de protéger leur entourage mais aussi de
protéger le sapeur-pompier de risque de
contamination mais d'amendé pardonnez
moi si on intervention un pompier
opposés à la vaccination obligatoire et
non vaccinés est malade et transmet le
comique qu'est ce qui se passe ensuite
alors il n'y aura plus de produire un
seul membre non vacciner puisque
l'obligation convient à mettre à l'écart
le sapeur pompier et à ne plus le
rémunérer donc que la france ne
s'inquiète pas en parlant de nos desdits
respectueux de tous les qualificatifs
qui sont utilisés aujourd'hui c'est
proprement de ski ferment de de
communication c'est de monter les uns
contre les autres les non vaccinés
contre les vaccinés enfin c'est une
exploitation qui est propre au nom
désastreuses en termes d'affichage
non il n'y aura pas de pompiers qui
interviendront à partir duquel c'est
pour venir à plus de points qui encaisse
septembre donc des gens ne s'inquiètent
pas c'est une forme de boutade mais pour
toi voilà voilà le schéma ni soignants
dix pompiers ni d'autres professions non
autrui pour autorisation d'exercer le 15
septembre
s'ils ne sont pas vaccinés ne produisent
pas les éléments nécessaires pour
l'exécutif et une très grande majorité
des professionnels de la santé la
vaccination est le principal rempart
contre le combi de 19
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez je ne
leur est pas rien simplement parce que
je ne relève pas de départ compétence
scientifique ou médicale s'est dit
simplement ces voix là il ya un certain
nombre de sapeurs pompiers qui ne
souhaitent pas être obligé à se vacciner
c'est c'est comme tout ce toutou
concitoyens c'est une expression
donc il faut que tout le monde le
comprenne le sapeur-pompier départ
vettel échanges il a le droit de
réfléchir aussi on a l'impression que
parce que nous assurons un service
public nous n'avons pas le droit de
réfléchir pas le droit de nous exprimer
pas le droit de d'affiché quoi que ce
soit on est devenue aujourd'hui la cible
la cible d'attaqués de de certains qui
en mettent en cause notre droit
d'expression
quid du
suivi de cette grève le suivi la grève
démarre à minuit ceux qui pètent s'ils
s'y attacher elles rendent le vent tout
simplement
ensuite on verra quels sont les
discussions qui seront peut-être
organisée par le gouvernement
il ya des dispositions claires détecte
les écrits qui ne sont pas justes qui ne
sont juste tout faire dans la
précipitation
ce n'est pas l'idéal je prends l'exemple
de demander aux pompiers de participer
la campagne vaccinale alors que cela
relève d'un acte médical qui doit être
pratiquée par un médecin et l'infirmier
nous y étaient opposés le pompier ne
peut pas tout faire c'est un couteau
suisse qui va signer l'épreuve
non c'est un acte médical qui ont la
venue d'un médecin ou d'un infirmier
ce sont des prises de position pour
prendre à l'impression d'être utilisée
comme moyen de communication d'un
fichage puisque la la la la population
reconnaît effectivement le travail des
sapeurs pompiers
mais pour toi nous avons le droit aussi
de nous exprimer et message est passé
merci andré goretti d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le porte parole du syndicat de
sapeurs-pompiers f as sppp ats